we are all here I'm Nick Gillespie with
reason I'm an editor at large there and
today I'm joined by my reason colleagues
Zach weismuller who is a video producer
I think he's a senior producer or an OB
senior producer and Robbie Suave who is
a senior editor at reason magazine and
also uh co-hosts Rising on the hill uh a
website and YouTube channel every day
gents thanks for for joining me
good to see you Nick hi and uh what we
are talking about today in this recent
live stream is recent Revelations about
the inter uh interrelationship between
the DHS and other aspects of the federal
government and social media platforms
like Twitter like YouTube like Facebook
um let's get right to it
um Robbie what did we learn this week
that prompted this very conversation
sure so there was a new uh report from
the publication The Intercept about
efforts by the Department of Homeland
Security
to surveil police
Etc misinformation have conversations
about social media platforms about uh
content on them that the government
thinks is misinformation some of this
honestly frankly is not as
earth-shattering or new if you've been
kind of paying attention to these issues
I still think it was very helpful story
in in kind of elucidating the
relationship between National Security
officials and platform content
moderation really what the article does
a good job of is is showing how the
mission creep of the Department of
Homeland Security which is you know a
bush era terrorism fighting that's
ostensibly what its purpose is is to
oppose violence and terrorism into
um concerns about pure speech uh and and
in this my the just the thing I want to
read from this is that according to the
most recent Homeland Security review
that The Intercept obtained
um there the department plans to talk
Target inaccurate information on topics
such as the origins of the covid-19
pandemic racial Justice the U.S
withdrawal from Afghanistan the efficacy
of coveted vaccines and the nature of
U.S support to Ukraine
all of those things being policy topics
and which it is absolutely I think
legitimate to express a range of views I
I think social media ideally is a place
to discuss those issues and we're
learning that so many of the
questionable moderation decisions we've
seen on Twitter and Facebook and YouTube
and other places over the last few years
are actually not being freely and
independently chosen by those platforms
but are being pushed on them by the
government by law enforcement that's
what they were worried about yeah I mean
uh and my my job here today is as kind
of moderator is to kind of push you guys
on your knee-jerk libertarian responses
but uh you know Robbie briefly
um can you talk a little bit about how
you know is it you know it how exactly
are these decisions forced on Facebook
or uh you know YouTube Google Twitter or
is it more like uh you know what like
hey here's a bad thing that's going
around
you know you guys should be aware of it
look some of this stuff falls into a
gray middle Zone um I I don't I think in
many cases the government is not
explicitly violating for instance the
First Amendment they're not passing a
law that says Facebook has to take down
discussion of the lab leak Theory
um what they're doing instead is
arguably legal and constitutional maybe
but they are their agents uh including
not even in DHS but in the White House
itself we've now seen the emails Etc the
constant conversations between
government officials and they'll say
things like we're really concerned about
this content we think you should do
something about it you know be aware of
this and then the backdrop is we're
going to haul your CEO before Congress
next week and have him yelled at and
we're going to raise the prospect of
antitrust and we do all these things
section 230 might be up for grabs so
it's a kind of soft pressure that the
Cato Institute for instance is calling
jaw boning I like this term a great deal
I think we should get used to using it
where it's it's it's a it's a pressure
campaign and then sure you could say
that well some of this content is bad
bad fine it's not all bad some there are
legitimate things that have been uh
discussions that have been shot down on
covid topics and on uh obviously the the
laptop the hunter Biden laptop story we
talk about that if you want there are
legitimate conversations uh being
chilled at the behest of the federal
government it's very clear that's
happening but we don't know that the
hunter laptop the hunter Biden laptop we
don't know that it was the government
that said hey you know what this is a
bad story to be running a couple weeks
before the 2020 election
um and and I mean I guess what I'm
getting at here I share all of your
fears but why wouldn't we expect the
people you know the kind Souls at
Facebook or Twitter to be like you know
what this stuff is [ __ ] up we should
we should de-emphasize this organic
completely on the hunter Biden story
specifically I I actually I disagree I
think it was very much a part of a soft
pressure campaign I mean I've spoken to
people for my book on social media I
spoke to people at Facebook and I said
what goes into a decision like that one
to turn down that story out of fear that
it is misleading and they said they rely
on cues from the mainstream media and
from law enforcement so the fact that uh
and some of that is just the mainstream
media but the fact that 50 or however
many top uh law enforcement FBI NSA
former and current people sign a letter
and say this has all the Hallmarks of a
Russian disinformation campaign and
they've already been in conversation
with Facebook saying you've got to
really look out for Russia
black Facebook worked at DHS and vice
versa there's a revolving door
of course Facebook and we saw this and
we'll get to this in a second Mark
Zuckerberg was kind of suggesting that
oh well you know the FBI told them you
know a couple days before or you know a
couple weeks before the election and
others weird stuff coming be on the
lookout for it of course Facebook isn't
going to take responsibility for uh you
know
tamping down on that story uh you know I
I mean but aren't these companies run by
people who hate everything that the
hunter Biden laptop story and the New
York Post stand for so I mean it's you
know I I I I guess what I'm asking is
like how do we parse out and maybe it
doesn't matter the blame shifting that
goes on here well certainly there's
blame shifting going on but my my
suspicion my hunch my I really do think
this that if you had less if you didn't
have as much bad direction from the DHS
CDC FBI agents you would not have had as
much bad moderation of those subjects on
social media and I think we will agree
that the hunter Biden laptop story being
spiked at um at Twitter where you could
not even reference it or link to it or
anything
um that is pro that's the most egregious
uh example of you know kind of social
media de-platforming and then it was
also the its reach was heavily reduced
at Facebook
um but that's not the only thing we're
talking about in a lot of ways that
maybe we talk we might talk about that
too much because it's this everyday kind
of throttling of content that is
probably in the end more influential
yeah it also I mean it's very clear that
for instance Alex Berenson uh who is
someone I I strongly disagree with on a
lot of covet related topics but he was
specifically singled out and you can you
know you can see the emails the
documentation singled out by the White
House saying things like why is this
still guy still allowed on the platforms
for for again many of his statements
about vaccines I think are totally wrong
but one of the things they made him get
taken down for was saying that like the
vaccines are not going to work to stop
the spread of covid which now you're
allowed to say because now everyone can
concede that while they're still
preventing severe infection and death
they're a great idea it's particularly
if you're an at-risk category you know
don't mistake me I'm not saying anything
of that nature but uh he I think he
should have been allowed to say what he
was saying and and Twitter did not free
they didn't it wasn't of their own
volition they were they were job owned
into doing it if you look at the
documentation all right yeah well let's
let's go to Zach uh uh you know I I
guess Zach where do you stand on this
jaw burning issue is it you have
back in 2018 you you wrote a piece about
kind of the Unholy alliance between
government pressure and social media
platforms and they're they're seemingly
self-generated actions and things like
that but where where are you on you know
kind of job owning because why um you
know is that a bad thing the the
government does not have any statutory
uh control over Facebook Twitter social
media in the way that the FCC does have
statutory authority to regulate content
on broadcast and you know network uh
broadcast radio and TV you know why
should we care I mean why should of
course the government is going to do
this the real issue is how weak the
social media companies are when it comes
to free speech and heterodox thought
yeah my my interest in this really
intensified around 2017 2018 when a lot
of the discussion about what social
media should be started to shift very
dramatically basically after Trump won
the election there was all this talk of
Russian disinformation and suddenly the
found the founders and the CEOs of the
social media companies who had
previously
talked a pretty good game about we want
this to be a fairly free Marketplace of
ideas
um that that that entire notion of you
know kind of like what the the early
internet was started to be challenged
um and I think Robbie's right to really
frame this in terms of mission creep and
that's one thing that I thought the
intercept article did a really good job
with was they took this back to
um back when uh DHS partnered with uh
Twitter and other social media companies
to de-platform Isis and so that's like
an example of like okay we can all kind
of agree that Isis being on American
social media is a bad thing but this is
like exactly how Mission classic mission
creep yeah
you start with the terrorists then
usually it's like some sort of you know
illegal immigrants or very unpopular
domestic groups and then it just
continually expands to more and more
categories and I think that's what we're
seeing now and what really uh grabbed my
interest about this particular
um this this particular branch of DHS
that uh we're talking about was uh
earlier this year they put out this memo
about Miss dis and Mal information
and there's one item on there which I've
highlighted here that caught my
attention that said DHS is working with
public and private sector platforms as
well as foreign counterparts to identify
and evaluate MDM including false or
misleading narratives and conspiracy
theories spread on social media and so I
was I've been very curious about what is
the nature of that collaboration because
because the intercept article is you
know it sheds some light on that but I
think there's still more to be found and
hopefully more documents will be
forthcoming but it's hard to answer some
of these questions about
you know how far over the line is the
government stepping because
what we do know is so much of this has
happened through kind of back channels
and that is kind of the the fundamental
route of my problem here is the the lack
of transparency and the way that this
job owning kind of inherently works is
it it's meant to skirt all these legal
issues and kind of uh push aside any
like robust public debate about it and
I'm hoping that maybe this moment will
be the beginning of that much needed
conversation and well you know we'll
we'll talk a little bit uh in a bit
about Elon Musk coming in at Twitter
because that has revived a lot of you
know some optimism and a lot of the
worst elements of the way the media as
well as government officials talk about
this kind of stuff
um Zach why don't you run the clips that
we have or the clip we have of Jen
pasaki who the late lamented uh I mean
she's still alive but she's no longer on
TV every day so she might as well be
dead right Robbie but Jen Pataki talking
from uh is this from 2021 or is it from
earlier this year 2021 July 21. go to
this question of of okay what is what's
the exact relationship like and I'll
mention
um to you guys you I think this was
before you were at reason it might have
been before you were born but uh Salon
magazine or Salon website years ago did
a um they had this great expose about
how uh the parts of the federal
government it was the drug czar's office
was working its way into writers rooms
on TV shows sitcoms and dramas too you
know let's have some let's have some
story lines about how [ __ ] awful
drugs are you know in you know Doogie
Hauser MD and you know uh Hill Street
Blues and things like that and shows of
that nature and one of the the things
that blew people's minds was the fact
that this was happening but even more
than that that it was hidden
um so do your points act that I think we
all know of course the government is
going to do this uh and all sorts of
kind of you know soft power is going to
be pushed but understanding that and to
get to this clip one of the things
that's interesting is you know so it's
from a year ago and uh Jeff is hockey is
talking like openly about this so why
don't we run that action Alex that we
have taken or we're working to take I
should say from the federal government
we've increased disinformation research
and tracking within the surgeon
general's office we're flagging
problematic posts for Facebook that
spread this information I would say
first it shouldn't come as any surprise
that we're in regular touch with social
media platforms just like we're in
regular touch with all of you and your
media Outlets about uh areas where we
have concern uh information that might
be useful information that may or may
not be interesting to your viewers you
all make decisions just like the social
media platforms make decisions even
though they're a private sector company
and different but just as an example so
we're regularly making sure social media
platforms are aware of the latest
narratives dangerous to Public Health
that we and many other Americans seeing
are seeing across all of Social and
traditional media and we work to engage
with them to better understand the
enforcement of social media platform
policies
all right so in a way the the The
Intercept story doesn't really advance
that understanding it gives us a few
more details but it's good to be
reminded of this right
yeah and uh this is like the kind of I
get I don't know if you call it
plausible deniability or just like the
fine line that they're walking here is
they're always uh all the documentation
has come forward so far there's they've
been very careful to you know put little
disclaimers at the bottom of the email
saying like we are not requiring that
you do this or these are just you know
strong suggestions but part of the
problem for me is that is backed by an
underlying threat that uh is hanging
over the heads of the tech companies and
that that both parties are responsible
for hanging over their heads namely the
threat to revoke uh section 230
protections and just to remind everyone
that is the liability protection that
that kind of makes Facebook and Twitter
possible where just because some person
posts something crazy on their network
uh they are not held responsible for
that and there's kind of a long paper
trail of politicians of both parties
saying you know you better kind of like
March to the tune we're playing or we
could always yank this you know and so
that is why this this entire situation
makes me very uncomfortable and
hopefully we you know we can talk about
some potential solutions to that uh that
would be amenable to Libertarians let's
dilate a little bit on on the section
230 question but then uh you know and
and also we can talk about the lawsuit
that has also helped to push the
intercept article uh that was uh
launched by Missouri attorney general
and Senate candidate Matt Schmidt who is
uh you know effectively an ambulance
Chaser he's uh he's introduced something
like 25 lawsuits against the Biden
Administration in 20 months of you know
of you know bidenism and whatnot
um but Robbie is it really right to say
oh well you know because politicians
talk about getting rid of section 230
which is a law or changing the law that
should they not ever talk about what
happens on social media I mean that
seems ridiculous to me from and again
I'm trying to Steel Man the argument
here of like it is a uh it's a wrong
form of government power for people in
the senate or the house to say you know
what like section 230 should be yanked
yeah a lot to get into there I so I
don't I think it would be a mistake to
change section 230 from a just from a
pure I want more speech on the internet
and the and no one in the like
Republican universe or Democratic
Universe everyone who's mad about
section 230 wants it revoked no one has
been able to explain how that would help
the climate of free speech because it
obviously transparently would not if you
make the com the platforms more liable
for the speech they're going to restrict
more of it and that's the exact thing
Republicans are trying to avoid they
claim so I don't know I don't get it
that said look I understand a little bit
so I don't favor changing it for that
reason I do understand I think the the
more thoughtful criticism of it is that
here's a shield for liability that
online platforms are enjoying the
traditional media companies are not
enjoying and so there is a kind of
um so anyway you could already do when
they're online in their online
components
misinformation is more more
self-policing or policing via the kind
of tort system for Simon and Schuster or
the Atlantic for their for their
physical editions in a way that it's not
self-policing on Twitter or on Facebook
because they have this greater
protection so I understand that honestly
if I were to try to make this consistent
I would be more inclined to just extend
the liability protections to all
traditional Publishers in a you know
what is isn't defamation in some sense a
an assault on the there on the concept
of free speech I would be more inclined
to fix things that way than than cause
there to be more where were you when
Alex Jones needed you most right I
Island you know I know I was probably
sitting right in here but uh let's uh
just run through a couple of quick
questions we're trying to involve the
audience as much as possible and I want
to thank Chuck E cheese uh you know the
wonderful children's uh pizza and beer I
was going to say wonderful children's
pizza and beer restaurant the beer is
obviously for the parents uh he says I
think the only question was how much and
how direct was the control of the
platforms uh Benjamin Dover says Jack
Dorsey has a new project called Blue Sky
that may be the way forward and Mott's
Bureau
uh which I feel like is a dick hurts in
a in a Nordic language that I'm not
getting uh most governments in the world
and especially in the western world are
actively reviewing how to regulate the
toxicity of disinformation
and misinformation on social media this
is a global problem
uh Zach why don't we uh start with that
uh you know with Chuck E Cheese's uh
inquiry of the question is how much and
how direct do you you know do you have a
sense of that or is this you know and
and how much does that kind of worry you
when we're talking about this sort of uh
topic yeah I mean that is the the Crux
of the issue is uh it's still in that
gray area that we're we're trying to
Grapple with I mean one thing that I
think of sometimes when I'm thinking
about this is I did a video uh in La
about a burger joint that was uh being
threatened because in La they just
declare that your business is a nuisance
if it attracts you know Riff Raff or
something and basically the police are
like well if you pay to install the
security system and like live you know
uh stream all the footage to our
headquarters then uh maybe we won't hit
you with this nuisance abatement charge
and shut down your business this is kind
of like a similar Dynamic I feel where
um what they're doing maybe technically
legal and I'm sure they're you know they
have teams of attorneys that are you
know tiptoeing uh up to the line to make
sure they don't violate the First
Amendment
but so far I I don't think that the the
um the intercept story has really shown
anything that's quite
stepped over that line I mean the most
one of the most disturbing details to me
there was like this uh that Facebook set
up uh special content uh removal portal
so this is just for government agents to
log in
flag things that they think should be
removed and then you know Facebook
decides what to do from there it's just
kind of creating that special
relationship everyone has the
opportunity to flag things that they are
they think are are bad or misinformation
or abusive or whatever but just setting
up that system setting up the closed
circuit uh
um surveillance system that goes
directly to Police Headquarters and then
like you know partnering in in this way
to
um police speech
um in a way that we saw went I think
terribly awry in several respects over
the past couple years
um needs like we need to question that
relationship how that relationship came
to be and what if anything can be done
um to restrain law enforcement or even
roll back the scope that some of these
agencies have to even weigh in on these
questions what's your best example Zach
of
uh you know of an instance where
government job owning or kind of strong
arming or DHS in particular really uh
shut down conversation that should have
been happening
well you know I I I do think that the
the hunter Biden laptop is the kind of
strongest example but right there's also
um I but also the most obvious right
because we all knew about that so but
but this like I said this this stretches
uh way back uh like what might help
actually would be to play a clip that
clip from my uh documentary from 2018
right now sure because this shows uh
kind of the exact dynamic I'm talking
about
um yeah let's do that and you also you
get a royalty every time we play this so
you get like three quarters of a penny
so let's let's do this type of War has
emerged information Warfare this
activity by the Russians is going to go
down in history as the greatest covert
action campaign in the history of Mother
Russia so-called fake news can have real
world consequences it's a danger that
must be addressed and you have to be the
ones to do something about it or we will
last October both houses of Congress
grilled the attorneys for the tech
Giants Facebook Twitter and Google about
Russian meddling and so-called fake news
you have been identified as the major
Distributors of fake news we are not
going to go away gentlemen their
strategy is to take a crack in our
society and turn it into a Chasm and
it's not just foreign misinformation
some lawmakers want better policing of
sites like Infowars the Austin
texas-based conspiracy site run by Alex
Jones a short time ago on Twitter if you
clicked on the hashtag NYC terrorist
attack the top tweet links to an
Infowars story with the headline Imam I
warned de Blasio about New York City at
Terror he was too busy bashing Trump do
you have a responsibility to flag
something as this was fake news we see
our users do that a lot we're an open
public platform you must feel like you
have some responsibility we are we are
deeply concerned about that and figuring
out ways we can do it with the right
balance while Democrats seem concerned
that tech companies don't do enough to
police content on their platforms
Republicans and conservatives have
expressed concern that they do too much
to cultivate their users news feeds your
power sometimes scares me do you
consider your sights to be neutral
public forum Google should be regulated
like the public utility it is because
customers can always log off these
companies already have strong incentives
to keep their platforms relatively free
of bots and trolls and to improve the
user experience through actively
curating content what we're trying to do
actually is provide each user a
personalized news feed that will be the
content that's most interesting to that
user treating social media as some sort
of public utility is quite simply a
power grab that all but guarantees
politicians and unelected bureaucrats
will decide what information should
appear in Americans news feeds and would
likely Grant the government even greater
access to our private Communications
than it already has are you intending to
turn over the committee any kind of
direct messaging that went on among the
different accounts track messages are
the private communication between our
users and so we take that privacy right
and responsibility very seriously we
don't want to put ourselves in the
position of being the Arbiter of Truth
we don't think that's a tenable position
for any company or industry it's
probably true that Facebook Twitter and
Google aren't in a great position to be
the Arbiters of truth but the government
is in an even worse position
yeah it was just really striking to me
that that last line where you know the
Facebook representative saying we don't
want to be the Arbiter of Truth and this
was just four years ago and I feel like
that entire attitude has just been you
know relegated to the Dustbin of history
or something uh but the point I wanted
you know make in showing that was just
that there is a definite pressure
campaign that you see there on on these
companies and they're you know cowering
before uh the the Senators and the the
representatives
um and and that's you know all fine
that's that's all part of the political
process but
um once you have law enforcement
uh kind of making these suggestions with
that as the background
um that it that is what's concerning to
me and you know when they went into some
examples with Infowars and stuff like
like this is all there's like a thousand
small examples like that so it's hard to
just like you know pick one that we keep
going back to the 100 Biden one because
that's that's the biggest one that
everyone remembers but it if it's
affecting a whole giant uh ecosystem
well let's you know let's talk about
Infowars um and you know for a couple of
reasons one is you know Alex Jones has
basically been banned from every
platform uh and he recently had a
massive nearly billion dollar default or
uh defamation settlement leveled against
him with more cases to come Robbie uh
you know looking at those clips uh it's
funny because like I'm kind of like hey
you know I like the fact that Facebook
and Twitter
people are saying hey you know we're not
going to be in charge of stuff and there
are private Communications that take
place I mean I was maybe you know they
at least had a couple of teeth left in
them when they were talking 2018. do you
think the situation has degraded since
then and why if so why
yeah it's certainly degraded and the
pandemic is part of that um the the
social media sites handling of covid was
really really really bad I I think to
sum it up I mean the fact that you could
not Facebook would not let you discuss
the lab League Theory uh very Brazen
takedowns of any discussion of the idea
that covid's Origins are that Wuhan lab
um and and we're I think we're still
learning the extent to which that was
another example of job owning I would
like to see more documentation there
before I conclusively State they did
this because you know here's the
official at the CDC who told them
yeah it could be just that there were
people in charge of Facebook who were
like I [ __ ] hate the lab League
Theory I think that's you know Trump
derangement syndrome or something so
we're going to count it yeah I mean they
they clearly though aren't they're
they're inspired to do that by the I
mean look at the commentary in the
mainstream media right The Washington
Post says that theory is a racist
conspiracy theory certainly the social
media companies just respond to that and
that's obviously that's not job owning
because those are other media companies
Etc that can manufacture consensus in a
bad way but is not really a government
category but it would it would shock me
if we never find a you know an email
from the CDC or whoever saying like hey
we were really concerned about the level
of lab League discourse on this platform
I bet we'll see that eventually and and
to be clear that is a really egregious
example of a bad content moderation call
now you are free to talk about it
because there is now enough
circumstantial evidence to conclude that
it is as likely an origin for the
pandemic I personally think it is the
more likely origin
um you know we'll still be learning for
years but that was bad and then so many
other coveted topics right and I you
know I understand that the certain I've
we wanted to feel the certainty for
vaccines and for other things I I and
again I do think the vaccines do a lot
we have a lot of evidence for their
efficacy in terms of severe disease and
death but but on vaccines and masks when
when claims didn't you know then they
got eventually final even Health
mainstream Health people like Leanna Wen
and like Rachelle wolensky you know are
now saying things about these these
efforts that you were not allowed to say
on social media a year ago and part of
that is is a changing scientific
consensus but then it's like well if we
don't if the scientific consensus
doesn't know yet you get to cut off the
discussion here and again these are
private platforms yes they can do that
but you know what was the government
telling them and it what we've been able
to see so far is it's just very and it's
so far outside of the of the law
enforcement or national security
justification that's the really scary
thing but yeah this is not yeah during
World War II right or troop movements or
something this is
um you know Zach um let's talk about the
lawsuit uh that the Missouri AG has has
launched and talk a little bit about
some of his you know co uh plaintiffs
and Robbie this is like I'm sure you're
on top of this too but like what amazing
is the collection of people who are
involved in the suit and they all are
you know they all hate section 230 230
is part of the thing that has to go
based on this Missouri lawsuit but
um Zach why don't you talk a little bit
about that I mean this is just the the
opening page of the lawsuit you can see
some of the parties listed the state of
Missouri state of Louisiana Dr
bhattacharya Who we've interviewed
before and uh who was the subject of a
um kind of one of these behind the
scenes campaigns where
um like people like Francis Collins were
saying anyone affiliated with the Great
Barrington declaration uh they were
sending you know out to Media sources
saying we need or or they were they're
kind of just privately talking saying we
need to kind of discredit this on on a
massive scale that is not really exactly
what I'm talking about but I assume I I
mean they're they're it's not good yeah
but they're and their attachment to the
suit is really I think they're claiming
that you know their posts were de-ranked
as part of like a sustained um effort
um will remind us who remind us who Jim
hoft is though what what great Patriot
and you know Galaxy brain is Jim Hoff
yeah
I mean I'm not that familiar with the
Gateway pundit I just know him as a kind
of like right-wing blog that uh is very
Trump friendly and you know puts out end
is wrong it's there you know and I'm
speaking figuratively here but he is
almost always wrong and he just puts out
kind of horseshit you know so and then
these are the people what do they what
are they hoping to do with this lawsuit
yeah and so they're going up against
Biden
um the press secretary the Surgeon
General
um the Department of Health and Human
Services head
um and they're claiming here that that
is that the social media and government
or that the government is engaged in a
First Amendment violation because the
government cannot accomplish through
threats of adverse government action
what the Constitution prohibits it from
doing directly so they're taking things
you know kind of a step further than
what we're saying here they claim to
believe the that or that they believe
that this is actually Stepping Over The
Line uh that this constitutes coercion
and censorship uh they mentioned section
230 which they are clearly against for
some reason but also they think that
section the what I was talking about
earlier the idea of taking section 230
is the threat that the government is
using to pressure the uh tech companies
which I I agree with
um but I think that the answer to that
is probably to protect and for you know
fortify section 230 expand its
protections like Robbie was saying not
to uh gut it
um and then they have a kind of a list
of different threats that politicians
have made here about revoking section
230 which we kind of saw some of that in
the clip that I played earlier so that's
the substance of the lawsuit
um what do we make of the fact that
um you know both Republicans and
Democrats conservatives and liberals uh
Libertarians and progressives uh we see
all coming together to say you know
section 230 is problematic is that a
sign that regulation is coming is it a
sign that these once great Giants of
post-industrial America Facebook Twitter
Etc are now kind of useless and then
they're open to you know they're open to
being regulated I mean that was one of
the big things in 2018 was to see people
like Mark Zuckerberg say hey it's a good
idea for us to be regulated we'll help
you write the regulation uh Robbie what
do you you know what what do we take
from yeah
with full knowledge that it would hurt
Twitter more than it would hurt Facebook
because Twitter is a smaller more
upstart company they cannot necessarily
afford the level of moderation that
would be required if you got rid of
section 230 which tells you you know the
kind of croniest impulses here I guess I
don't so I right like Zach totally
disagree with the section 230 element of
this lawsuit
um I don't mind as much given that the
lawsuit is is directed at government
officials and this is the direction I
want to move the conversation far too
many conservatives and Republicans have
directed their fire at social media
companies for bad moderation decisions
we are learning for various reasons that
a lot of this is coming is is being done
at the behest of the government in some
way or another let's direct our fire at
the government when Facebook takes you
know Twitter kicks someone off for
coveted misinformation instead of saying
boohoo Twitter censorship we should do
something to hurt Twitter which would
just be like shooting ourselves in the
book in the foot because overall social
media is good for spreading provocative
and contrarian and libertarian views
let's not like do that instead can we do
something to like stop the CDC from
doing that like the the thing we have
control over technically in a democracy
and like we have some ostensible control
right over the federal agencies and the
people who staff them so let's let's
yeah sue them if there's something to
sue them over or come up with some or or
you know vote them out replace them
support candidates who want to put a
muzzle on uh you know Dr fauci's
enforcers or something I am far more in
favor of that don't like the social
media companies are the victims to some
extent and conservatives have really
abdicated their role as like Defenders
of I I like free marketplaces or you
know limited government right yeah I
mean they've obviously abdicated their
defenses of everything it doesn't but
would it be helpful if we as a
Libertarians stop talking about the
government as if you know the CDC the
FCC the DHS and the Senate and the House
of Representatives are all the same
thing because in fact you know does it
matter if it's DHS or uh the CDC or
executive branch agencies that are
pushing things versus legislators yeah
well it does matter
um yeah we'll go well and also it
matters from again DHS if DHS is using
that extra Facebook link to for that
that uh that portal to flag right here
is Isis here's a militia group here look
I I think there's a legitimate if
government's only purpose is
legitimately deterring violence National
Security Etc I don't have a problem with
them doing that if it's you know
narrowly on actually a flagging and
taking down organized violence sure fine
that's dhs's role but with the CDC they
don't have they absolutely do not should
not have the authority to dictate to
social media companies what you're
allowed to say about covid mitigation
efforts they've gone so far it's really
the coveted stuff for me at least that
they have gone so far overboard
um with that that uh that I'm very wary
and it and then and it's been wrong so
many times so that so yeah if you want
to start you know pulling things apart
that's where we should really focus a
lot of our outrage in my view Zach what
do you think about that generally and
then also this these topics are
epistemological categories of
misinformation disinformation Mal
information they get talked about as if
they are self-evident and we all agree
on you know this is misinformation
that's disinformation this is Mal
information all right is that part of
the craziness here which is you know
what in a world in a country of 330
billion people you know your
misinformation might be my mail
information or simply my absolutely
obvious truth um yeah this is where I
think we've gone way off course because
um you know this this
um branch of the DHS that is responsible
for a lot of the sisa which was created
by the Trump Administration
um in Congress I mean the law that you
know the law that put it into being was
a republican-controlled congress in 2006
the the the Cyber infrastructure
Security Agency uh and the point of that
agency was National Security National
Defense some big firms had gotten hacked
um there's foreign governments behind
some of these major data breaches so you
know it sounds reasonable but in their
their they put out pretty soon after the
byte Administration came into power they
started putting out these documents
saying well actually disinformation
misinformation
malinformation which is true information
that is you know harmful to people
things like revenge porn
um these are also threats to the
Homeland these are threats to National
Security and therefore this is within
our purview and that to me is the
problem that this Mission creep has now
we the federal government has taken it
for granted that this is their job and
the social media companies have been
forced to capitulate to that and the
kind of action that I would like to see
I'm not a legislature so a legislator so
I don't know what the exact law should
be but something to restrain the scope
of action of these kinds of agencies and
restrain their ability to uh have these
kind of conversations you know if the
CDC wants to put out guidance and then
Facebook book or YouTube want to abide
by CDC guidance in terms of how they
allow what's on their platform that's
one thing but to have this special
relationship that is something that I
feel that our lawmakers could actually
tackle and I'm not optimistic that it's
going to solve the whole problem
ultimately I think technological
solutions are the only like true
Safeguard here but I would still like to
see it attempted could you talk just
briefly about and then Robbie I'll come
to you to ask about media literacy as
another way of dealing with this rather
than government control or or even
corporate control what are some of the
technological advances Zach that you
think would change this discussion or or
make this kind of question just go away
yeah so I'm going to pull up one of the
questions that you went to earlier Jack
Dorsey has a new project called Blue Sky
that may be the way forward from
Benjamin Dover and um Blue Sky was
basically before Jack headed for the
exit he set up this team to try to
decentralize Twitter's uh protocol so
that Twitter the the idea was eventually
Twitter could become interoperable with
other social networks so your data would
kind of be portable and if you don't
like what Twitter's doing you can still
keep all your followers you can still
kind of keep that Network and your
history intact but you know take it
elsewhere and I think Jack is is kind of
a Visionary in that sense um that might
be why he got out because he saw it
wasn't going in the direction he wanted
to go uh that he was hoping would go
maybe things will change with uh a new
captain at Twitter uh but um there's
also you know the rise of these uh um
you know encrypted Network works like
signal and telegram which got a huge
influx of users after what we call the
great D platforming of 2021 which uh you
know when Trump was kicked off but also
he was kind of the Big Kahuna but then a
bunch of other people got booted at that
time and everyone uh you know these
these encrypted platforms started
getting a lot more users and you know
they're not as big as Twitter but I
think of these these platforms that are
kind of designed to be harder to control
as safety valves that we want to always
have so they might be more chaotic they
might have more nasty stuff on them they
might not be where you want to even hang
out most of the time but they exist just
in case uh things you know get bad and
so that that's what I mean I say that
the technological solutions are really
the the the kind of final bulwark there
you know I will uh recommend to
everybody who's listening to this to
read Arthur E kirch's the decline line
of American liberalism a book that was
originally published in the 50s but it's
a Libertarian classical reading of
American history as always a kind of
battle between forces of centralization
and decentralization and you know just
you go through eras where things are
getting more centralized and then things
are getting more dispersed and the
internet you know Lord Lovett as a major
medium really only dates back to the mid
90s maybe some people would even say in
the early 2000s but you know we've gone
through these cycles of centralization
and decentralization or dispersion and
centralization Balaji Sierra Nevada
talks about this in the network State uh
quite a bit and we're clearly you know
we we've gone through a decade or more
of centralization and it seems like
people are interested in a dispersion
effect so you know you see a lot of that
Robbie so you know part of that is
technological like how do you know you
it's hard to shut down conversations
that are happening on you know WhatsApp
groups or you know telegram or signal
but it also means that the groups are
going to be smaller we saw this with
Facebook Facebook groups which were kind
of private can be you know just
destroyed overnight if Facebook chooses
to that's a that's a technological issue
and I think most Libertarians would be
like yeah yeah we want to have lots of
different solar systems out there that
you can travel among in between some of
them are going to be bigger and more
centralized some or not but let's talk
about media literacy as a function here
of like you know would it be better if
we were while we're looking at legal
things to say the government can't do
these certain types of things and we're
looking at technological fixes you know
uh dorsey's been talking about blue sky
for a number of years now let's finally
see it okay
um but then this question of the end
user you me Zach everybody else like how
do we need to change how we consume and
produce media whether it's on a social
media plan platform or the internet so
that we stop having this horrible stupid
conversation about what is and is not
allowable speech well I mean the the
media the mainstream media's sort of
obsession with misinformation and
disinformation has given me a lot of
pause about enforcement or fact checking
or the whole concept because
I have no I cannot notice any everyone
who purports to have some expertise in
this and it like is a is a
misinformation beat reporter for let's
say the Washington Post or the New York
Times or someone else they seem no more
likely to they seem just as likely as
anyone else to fall for misinformation I
mean like this was the this was the
whole criticism of Nina jankowicz the
person who has briefly put in charge of
this Homeland Security disinformation
Board and you know she was one of those
voices saying the hunter Biden laptop is
Russian disinformation and so and and so
and you know with no later confession
that oops I really got that a very
important story wrong so again
a whole host of people in the government
but you know including like the FBI and
whatnot but also in the media who are
like no there's no question that Putin
was calling the shots for Trump the
whole Russia get story or narrative
whatever you want to call it it's just
[ __ ] in the way add to that absolute
unimpeachable fact right it was a bunch
of Facebook groups and things that like
a small fraction of users saw it it like
the way they talk about the Russian uh
what happened in 2016 as is it it's as
if Russia was like had hacked the the
voting machines and changed the outcome
but uh but and back to you know
jakeowitz so that was I think a
legitimate criticism of her that she you
know she's not even-handed she had
missed this really she gotten this
really important story wrong and then
right everybody gets very upset about
him they shut it down and then that what
you just put up on screen uh that was my
response to the Washington Post article
you know lamenting how unfairly This
Woman's life had been ruined her her
dream shattered oh no and the Washington
Post write-up you know done by uh again
someone who's like an expert in the tech
space purportedly an expert in the tech
space in the misinformation space that
article did not once mention the chief
criticism of Nina jankowicz which which
was that her judgment is suspect because
she screwed up on a couple subjects most
notably under Biden there are so many
examples of so with the the the guard
the Guardians the people who want to
keep you safe for misinformation have
this totally paranoid and conspiratorial
view of it like it's a virus you're in
danger of catching unless they stamp it
out and actually they they overlap
substantially with like the most Pro
lockdown or you know where a long covet
is disabling us this is the Mandarin
class right yeah yeah educated and know
well and are anointed by whatever you
know they get it wrong all the time they
get it wrong all the time and so I don't
wanna I don't want them to police I
don't think they should be policing our
our discourse how do individuals though
guard themselves against being suckers
for the dumbest theory that seems pretty
good because a lot of you know a lot of
conspiracy I mean you know there's one
thing there's conspiracy theories but
then there are these you know sober
analytical understandings of science or
of history or of communications you know
how do we how do we force the fact
checking mechanism down to the
individual user in a more effective way
so that they stop saying you have to
believe what I believe otherwise you
know you have to be silenced I wish more
people would subscribe to reason
magazine but uh but only uh 1997 for 11
issues or the online version and then
it's a little bit more you can have both
but I think people came back to 1968
should get used it I think it's useful
to consume many different media I mean
there's studies showing you know that
when people uh because there's the topic
selection and topic-wise like if you're
only watching fox or you're only
watching CNN it's not so if you're only
watching CNN and then you start watching
Fox I think you're not likely to change
your mind on very many things but you're
going to be aware aware of topics of
stories of things other people care
about that you had no idea because
you'll you'll have you might have no
idea that crime in Philadelphia is out
of freaking control right now if you're
only watching MSNBC you might think you
know drag queens are sexually assaulting
every child on Earth if you're only
watching Fox you like the the oh it's
helpful to get your news from a variety
of sources I mean I was I got really
really testy with a lot of this
right-wing conspiracy about the Paul
Pelosi story it was totally based in
nonsense this is an elderly man who is
the victim of a really terrifying home
invasionally
harmless by a mentally homeless person
and conservatives are I think not
wrongly concerned about the mental
illness in in our streets and so I I
live in a city that has been clearly
affected by
um mentally ill people and homelessness
and because conservatives are very
worried about this and are I think maybe
rightly impuning not always but
sometimes some democratic policy choices
on this and then they're going to turn
around we have a clear example of it and
they turn around and pretend first
there's no information now there is
information absolutely confirming that a
crazy homeless person came in and
attacked us man and and there you have
Donald Trump and Donald Trump Jr and
other right-wing figures you know
putting out like utterly unfounded
funny to them ideas about it it's really
it's despicable and irresponsible and
and that if you are only getting your
news from one ideological Source or
another you're gonna fall prey to more
of these things Zach uh we also saw the
new owner of Twitter Elon Musk and it's
been almost a week you know so we know
exactly how all of this is going to play
out and Twitter went from being a
shining City on the hill you know it was
on the Cyber Hill to being an absolute
hellscape that uh you know we've never
seen the likes of before he shared the
story that first put into play uh from
the Santa it's a website based in Santa
Monica California now Paul palesi this
was a homosexual pickup gone wrong
um are you do you think do you think
Elon musk's Twitter is this more of the
same kind of just [ __ ] annoying story
or is this maybe the beginning of a new
day that um you know for social media
where big social media companies are
going to be like [ __ ] you we we are
actually going to be staging Free Speech
rather than that I'll say I'm cautiously
hopeful uh that that might be the case
and you know the fact that Elon Musk
shared this kind of [ __ ] story
um and then it got wide circulation in
part because of that
um it's kind of an example of how this
stuff can just work itself out in a way
like
most like yes there's always going to be
the echo Chambers where people aren't
going to ever let go of that narrative
but it's like okay that's that rumor
swirled for a while and now most like
level-headed people realize what
actually happened
um and we can get back to talking about
all the uh vote mules that Dinesh
D'Souza brought to our attention a
couple months ago
yeah it's kind of embarrassing for Elon
Musk but he can embarrass himself on his
own platform now that's that's kind of
great too
um and you know I like being in his
living room in his you know fifty
thousand dollar prefab house in the
Texas desert it's so nice it's gonna I
think it's gonna be a real test because
I think he does seem to want to take a
much more laissez-faire approach um at
least that's what he says he wants to do
we'll see how the implementation goes
and that's what we want as a remedy to
all these problems is more competition
different approaches uh but the more
that the government is able to job own
these companies uh the less we're going
to be able to see that kind of
competition play out you know the media
literacy problem is a tough one we're
all coping with you know digital media
and trying to figure out how to deal
with the information overload
um and it's just
going to be a process
um and government uh by trying to
um like gatekeep that too aggressively
is I think is only going to slow that
process down and really undermine it
from happening in a real way because
once you start aggressively
reining in what can be talked about then
even the kind of craziest theories get
this like forbidden uh Aura attached to
them as opposed to the Paul Pelosi story
which most most of us just look as this
like goofy thing that was my presumption
is kind of now that uh you know that
anything I see and particularly video or
audio that confirms what I want in my
darkest Heart of heart to be true
anything that confirms that I assume
it's a deep fake and you know you I mean
we're in an age now where I think you
should be skeptical of everything in the
question then is how do you how do you
remain skeptical in a positive
optimistic way without becoming a
nihilist you know and just becoming
totally cynical about everything
um Robbie uh our uh our social media
Maven uh best buyers has uh asked a
question that I think is worth uh kind
of thinking about she asks uh is it
possible for tech companies to ever
regain public trust after working with
the government to suppress covid
Hunter's laptop uh Etc and there's a lot
packed in there but you know it it's
going to be hard for the government to
win certainly to win over Libertarians
right I mean because you know that
that's oil and water but what are the
ways that you know what would what
should Elon Musk do what should Mark
Zuckerberg uh you know other than like
leaving Facebook behind and you know
going into a a virtual world where you
know you don't have legs yet but they're
coming
um you know what what can major
platforms do or or Platforms in
cyberspace in in social media due to to
actually Curry trust among their users
well it will be very harder a lot of
these platforms to regain trust with
certain segments of the population you
know competition is always a a thing
here there's going to be I don't think
Facebook will ever have the relevance uh
politically socially that it had in 2017
ever again I just don't expect it to
return that in 2010 right or 2012. yeah
that had a great run
foreign
I think that um was that the vaccine the
vaccine was getting in the way of you uh
having decent audio I assume yeah I just
had I just had to get my 80th jab you
know in order to hunt me down
um the uh like Tick Tock is a new you
know new platform that has different
strengths and weaknesses I think it
solves some of the Instagram
um negative body image issues that
Instagram has I think are much better on
Tick Tock because it's more
collaborative artistic platform but then
it has other because of the China
component there are other issues with it
um I the number one thing I would tell
Elon to do with Twitter is to Let's
devolve moderation to users as much as
possible if you should have you should
be able to check settings maybe you want
the moderation equivalent of whatever
the most like at a resistance liberal
has where you don't have to see anything
Brooklyn dad you want Brooklyn Dad's
feet Yes exactly yeah well then check
that setting and then those of us who
want a more are are not as afraid of of
contrasting views can have a different
setting let it let the users pick it
instead of having it um uh voice it on
them and and have that be true of have
that just be true of the of the the fact
checking experience as much as possible
Twitter fact checking program that it
has piloted and is rolling out as we
speak a bird watch which allows you it
functions more like Wikipedia users add
content notes and then users can check
those content known say well I like this
because it has a high quality link to a
trustworthy article it has facts in it
and Etc you can have all that stuff
happen and that is so much better than
what Facebook has done which is to
deputize a handful of ideological
extremists
um who who are just wrong all the time
on covet issues on climate issues
they've falsely fact checked me and then
I've complained and then they've said oh
just kidding sorry we got that wrong
they did that to John Stossel they they
they're they're so bad I cannot say
enough bad things about them Twitter is
is doing something that's closer to
Wikipedia that is the model let users
let the people decide democratize it
marketize it
um move in that direction
like with the the bird watch thing is
interesting too because you could
imagine these kind of like competing
gangs of fact Checkers
um and you kind of just subscribe
subscribe to the fact checking service
that tends to get it right uh more often
than not instead of like you said that
the kind of top-down deputization of the
people who have connections with
Facebook or Twitter
what uh what kind of amazes me and Zach
maybe you can speak to this is the idea
that you know social media companies
we've talked about this a little bit
they are taking cues from not only the
government you know and that like okay
well the government you know they've you
know they you know when the government
comes in and they lean over your desk
they make sure you see the gun that's in
their waistband so that's one thing but
they're taking their cues from places
like the Washington Post or CNN or the
New York Times and it's like you know
you guys are kind of competitors like
why would you do what a you know 150
year old media uh a medium is doing as
opposed to kind of going your own way
and offering something unique and
different that's of the moment
um do you think I mean is there a kind
of ideological capture or or kind of
like commercial capture of New Media now
that it's been around for you know 10 or
15 years
I mean I think so you can just go back
to the New York Post story again to see
that I mean this is I believe our
nation's oldest newspaper and uh you
know Twitter kind of like uh bigfooted
them uh using other their competitors
um and possibly some sort of faulty
Intel that was being fed to them to uh
squash them uh or you know suspend their
account for uh a long time I think it
was over a week
um so yeah it's it's kind of the wrong
way to go about it I think uh it's the
the going towards a more crowd-sourced
version
um and you know not picking your own
facts but at least being able to kind of
Select from a menu of fact Checkers uh
that over time will prove themselves
trustworthy
uh Robbie do you think is this a
symmetrical conversation that we're
having about you know facticity
um or factfulness whatever you want to
call it
um because you know there's there's no
question that like Democrats believe
that or liberals or progressives
whatever you want to call people that
are you know from the center to the left
believe some crazy stuff but Donald
Trump and the era of public discourse
right-wing discourse that he initiated
is you know really off the charts in
terms of that guy I mean he has not even
conceded the 2016 election which he won
because he says there were so many
stolen votes he would have had a
majority of the popular vote I mean this
guy is a [ __ ] liar you know every
morning he gets up and before he has
breakfast he's told a dozen lies and I'm
not saying anything about that I'm just
that's like just descriptive is that
part of the problem though that you know
one side in particular is just totally
uninterested in anything that might
approach uh you know objective fact yeah
I I don't have anything
um positive to say about uh Donald
Trump's contributions to the dialogue or
the any and also the you know the the
content moderation decision that he's at
the center of the decision to take him
off social media
um I I don't I I certainly think you can
construct a defense of it in the moment
it happened I don't know about keeping
him off forever yeah but um I I
absolutely and and I would argue this to
anyone anywhere
um I do hold him responsible for what
happened at the Capitol there is no
question that the things he was saying
at the time actually not things he was
saying on social media which makes it
interesting the decision to take him off
it's not because he was saying crazy
things on Twitter people the people who
marched to the capital you know smat and
broke all the windows uh clash with
police officers did it because of the
things he was saying like there on site
or down you know down the street he's
absolutely responsible for it it was not
I don't think it was illegal incitement
I think it was absolutely should have
been held responsible in the
Constitutional sense should have been
impeached and removed from office but
you know he was acquitted didn't happen
that's it I you know sometimes people
are acquitted and you don't like it but
it's over there's nothing more we can do
um from a legal standpoint a
constitutional standpoint except people
uh can hopefully vote to not have him be
a a factor in in the dialogue anymore
it's clear that smart Republicans
Republican leaders know that it is
better for the party if he's not on
social media and uh and are not I think
are probably not actually putting major
pressure on Elon to do anything about
that on Twitter
um but look I I take your your point uh
there's a lot of bad stuff uh going on
in in conservative media and dialogue
although you do get but then you also
get
um uh some some good pushback to
mainstream narratives in alternative
places uh yeah I think we at reason try
to model thoughtful uh pushback from an
alternative perspective without you know
without assuming well of course Paul
Pelosi was part of some gay orgy
we we you know we want to talk about uh
a lot of how covet has gone wrong a lot
of like Republicans right now are I
think are capitalizing on actual
dissatisfaction among people with our
Ukraine strategy right there's no it's
it's incredible but there is very little
opposition within Democrats the
Democratic circles to a blank check
we're going to give Ukraine as much
money for as long as possible without
making any sort of like hey we will cut
this off eventually if you don't have
some sort of negotiation with with Putin
there were 30 Democrats who tentatively
put out a letter to that effect and then
were forced a shamingly to walk it back
but some Republicans are charting a
different course so I I would never say
that like it's just not true that well
Democrats are you know they're maybe
they're misguided but they're getting
things right or Republicans are just you
know so reprehensible both sides are are
you it's a you don't want to say both
sides but it is true that they are on
different issues getting things wrong
reprehensibly ruining this country art
look at our debt look at our our whole
system broken because These two factions
just keep you know they have the wheel
and then they crash the car and then the
other person takes the the wheel and
they drive it into the sea and then the
editor takes the wheel and I don't know
they cause a comet to hit so it's like
uh Thelma and Louise the ending but like
they never hit bottom it's just like oh
Thelma I'm driving no Louise I'm driving
and it's yeah uh you know Zach uh we're
gonna we're gonna shut down in a couple
minutes here but
um you know
legislatively uh you know there are two
you know laws that were passed uh you
know that really deal directly with the
regulation of social media Platforms in
Texas and in Florida uh they've both
been held in abeyance because of uh
court rulings but
you know and they're both the product of
conservative legislatures and
conservative Governors uh Greg Abbott
and Ron DeSantis is that the biggest
threat facing us right now uh the kind
of legislative attempts to wrestle
corporate entities into some kind of
political you know Chokehold or is it
the ongoing you know kind of pipeline
between DHS you know and DHS exists
whether it's a Republican or a Democrat
um and they seem to always be kind of
talking with the the powers that be at
uh social media platforms where how do
you rank order these kinds of threats I
think these threats are actually related
um I I saw a question here that caught
my eye that's kind of along those lines
um this uh John Funk said I understand
that as quote Libertarians you can't
quote like Republican policies or
Democratic policies it seems the
Republican move to strip section 230
protections from platforms that are
actively curating content publishing
would be far preferable to the
Democratic policy of allowing
encouraging insisting on censoring of
misinformation a subjective term
um so this is like the bills that you're
talking about uh I'm more familiar with
the Florida one because I'm a Florida
man but uh where they're basically
trying uh DeSantis was trying to take
away the liability Protections in
Florida for everyone except for uh Walt
Disney corporation which he came around
to deal with he walked that one back
yeah yeah but um
the problem the the big mistake that
Republicans uh and conservatives have
made here and we saw it earlier in that
Montage where Tucker Carlson says these
need to be regulated like Public
Utilities is you are now trying to lock
in the monopolies like look at what just
has happened to meta in the past year
it's collapsing you know it's U.S user
base started collapsing four years ago
when these conversations were happening
and that's why Zuckerberg was writing
letters saying please regulate me
because he wanted to be one of the
protected members of the cartel and
Republicans are shooting themselves in
the foot by by pushing this forward we
we want competition to alleviate
um these problems you know uh whether it
is
um you know Elon taking over Twitter or
Trump starting truth social
um these these things exist uh and you
can support them or not support them
um but they're not going to exist uh if
you get rid of something like section
230 because then truth social with all
the [ __ ] I'm sure is floating around
there will get sued out of existence
immediately so if you want your kind of
crazy unhinged social media site which I
agree should exist you don't want to go
down this path and that that is where I
think that conservatives and especially
kind of the this populist Wing has
totally misrepresented what has actually
been happening
uh with social media and um has just
been offering terrible policy
prescriptions
um that would hurt all of us but well
and to me yeah yeah Robbie why don't you
Robbie Robbie take us home okay you
you'll get the last word here just and
just be clear like that question that
person who asked that question that
framing is just not correct because it's
not just the Republican proposal to do
that Democrats support that Democrats
want to strip section 230. Elizabeth
Warren supports doing that Bernie
Sanders supports doing that Joe
Biden supports doing that how is it good
for how could it imagine a universe
where Elizabeth Warren wants to do
something that will end up being good
for conservatives online I don't believe
that I believe she is a very Savvy
political operative who wants to harm
non-progressive speech online and knows
that getting rid of section 230 will
accomplish that because it would for the
reasons Zach just outlined so it's again
it's a non-starter for me because the
results would of of
imposing on platforms more liability to
speech will be less of my speech less of
your speech less conservative speech I'm
sure there'll be provocative Lefty type
people will also be punished anti-war
people Etc the mainstream consensus of
the New York Times and the mainstream
media and CNN is reinforced by imposing
guard rails on everyone else social
media is a great competitor to the
mainstream media it's been a great gift
to Alternative perspectives and we we
risk we do not want to go back to an era
before it let's talk about how to
improve it let's talk about other
opportunities but let's let destroying
it is a is a gift to the New York Times
it's based in a fantasy it's a fantasy
because their fantasy is that we just
need to get Republicans in power I guess
forever uh use section 230 to force the
social media
platforms to apply the First Amendment
to make their platforms neutral or some
something like that and then hope that
Democrats never take power again and
then use it for their own ends to shape
the platforms to have content moderation
policies they like like it makes no
sense um if you think about it for more
than 10 seconds we're not going to give
Gondor the weapon of the enemy we are
going to throw the ring in the [ __ ]
volcano that this is honestly it always
recombines but you know I was thinking
as we were talking about this and as The
Intercept story came out about a week
ago or so lucianne Goldberg died she is
the mother of Jonah Goldberg who was the
editor-in-chief of National Review
online which was the first kind of fully
formed website for uh a magazine really
a political magazine in the late 90s and
but lucianne Goldberg was Central to
destroying old gatekeeper news stuff uh
in the 90s having to do with the Monica
Lewinsky
um uh Scandal and also so founded
lucianne.com in the late 90s which was
this interesting you know kind of
user-based thing it was social media
before there was social media obviously
this is the covet police coming to
gatney my apartment
um but it was
um you know it's kind of timely uh
because it seems to me in a very real
way what some things that are going on
now is we're trying to get back to or
reinvigorate an earlier model of what
internet culture was all about which was
about distributed power distributed
information and the users determining
how what their experience of the network
was not the people you know not the
broadcasters not the people with the
command Towers but rather you know it's
it's all of us
um you know in our little cubby holes
our spider holes are you know our
laptops uh doing stuff so hopefully
we'll get there Robbie uh Suave thank
you so much uh where is the best place
to watch Rising every morning that you
it's on YouTube yeah head over to the
hills YouTube channel it's there and uh
yeah check it out thank you and uh Zach
uh my co-host uh on uh reason live
streams what do you have uh coming out
soon I have reason TV uh I just put out
some misinformation this morning about
the lab leak Theory uh it's an interview
with a health reporter who sketches out
the uh timeline that early timeline kind
of what Anthony fauci and his little
team of
um uh Public Health officials were
saying amongst themselves and how that
contrasts to the message uh that they
are broadcasting to the public all right
well we'll look for that that's all at
reason.com follow all of us at
raisin.com go to Reasons YouTube channel
our Facebook feed our Twitter feed our
Instagram feed and our Tick Tock uh
which is becoming more and more
electrifying with every day so thank you
all uh for uh participating and watching
the reason live stream
thanks Nick thank you